oh hiya ken uh i mean ryan gosling
bobby
check out the first pick of ryan as ken
from the live action barbie movie it's a
dream warner brothers the studio behind
the flick due out next year shared the
aptastic image there's ryan standing
outside what appears to be barbie's
dream house and everything is pink duh
[Music]
and ryan looks fantastic rocking
platinum blonde hair rock hard abs a sun
kissed tan
rock hard abs calvin klein inspired kin
underwear and oh did we mention rock
hard abs
so many it's hard to count
speaking of chiseled abs thanks to
ryan's barbie co-star simulu we now know
more about his training regimen he's
he's definitely like a gym in the
morning gym after work kind of guy and i
just um you know as much as i i believe
that i do have a work ethic i also
love
food
a lot
and you know just hearing little bits
and pieces about you know just his his
strict diet regimen and just like how
you know much emphasis he puts on taking
care of himself and his body i'm like i
i respect it i respect it i'm gonna have
some soda simu's been cryptic about his
role but he's hinted he's playing
another version of ken what he can
confirm
it's going to be big bright and bold i
feel like the less i tell you the better
because i feel like every little piece
of news that comes out to tease people
everyone just gets progressively more
confused and curious as to what this
movie is and i kind of like that i feel
like
i feel like july of next year when it
comes people are going to be really
really surprised um just fun just fun
colors like we're wearing bright vibrant
fun celebration
yeah as for barbie herself played by
margot robbie fans got a first look in
april at the actress's transformation
margot smiles ear to ear while sitting
in a pink convertible and rocks a blue
and white top complete with a matching
headband and bracelet
[Music]
and when easy spoke with margot last
year she left us with the tease that had
us ready to party with barbie expect the
unexpected it's not going to be whatever
you're thinking it's not it's not that
[Music]